[Music]
you
come back so in today's lecture we are
going to study about long-term memory
this is a part of memory which has been
discussed in that internship and model
and this is the kind of memory that
people when they collect early or when a
layman talks about memory this is the
kind of memory that they talk about so
what we're going to do in today's
lecture is will look into this kind of
memory so basically mostly tribals that
you have any kind of information that
you think of storing any kind of life
event knowledge any kind of facts any
kind of mathematical rule or any other
kind of information which you think is
stored in your mind or brain is
basically what is stored in the
long-term memory so let's then look at
what is long-term memory and in this
particular section we look into basic
processes of long-term memory as in how
it is formed and what are the basic
processes and kind of retrieval and all
and the upcoming couple of lectures we
look into different kinds of long-term
memory now continuing from what we saw
in the last class I discussed about
something called at kitchen and
reference model so at kitchen shiven
model or the information processing
model talks about a system which has
three parts into it a three part system
so what we have is a setup like this and
this is called the sensory register in
the last C's of last lectures we saw
what is sense a register and how does it
work and what are the various properties
of the sensory register so basically any
information which comes out or which
comes in or gets processed through the
perceptual and rational processes
basically arrive at the sensitivity
and it is a huge capacity very short
duration of time and then we have
something called the short-term store
this is another thing that we talked
about in our last lecture this is the
kind of system which shows information
from brief periods of time not very
brief but we could be periods of time
but it can hold only limited information
and we saw an extension of this concept
called the working memory in our last
class so working memory is basically an
improvement of the short-term store
because it talks about the system which
has more capacity then as was discussed
in that engine and Chafin model and
obviously the last thing that we didn't
discuss the last part we didn't discuss
was the LTM or the long-term memory this
is the store which holds most of the
information even the working memory as
we saw the capacity working memory
executed systems which basically make
decisions for the working memory system
they threw the episodic buffer connect
to this long-term store so this
long-term store then holds our most of
the information now that kitchen and
schriften model just just doesn't talk
about this kind of box and arrow
structure but they also talk about
processes and so these processes are the
ones which actually go ahead and
transfer information so here the process
here is the attentional processes water
so I'll write attention allocation here
so that is the process which takes an
information from the sense a register
and moves it to the short-term store and
once the information is in the store can
store it is basically the rehearsal
process which moves information from the
short-term store to the long-term store
so the number of rehearsals that we do
a number of repetitions that you do of
an information number of times you use
an information it basically goes to
something called the long-term store it
gets stored here now the long-term store
is not an active store as we discussed
in terms of the short term store we saw
the working memory concept describe the
short-term store is an active store said
it can do a lot of stuff it can move
around a lot of stuff it can do a lot of
activity but the long-term store doesn't
do any activity it is just like a kind
of storehouse which is there so
information are there a number of
information is stored here it is stored
in a highly organized and categorized
format but there is no action as such
which basically means that things cannot
be acted upon if a particular rule or if
a particular information needs some
action on it
some kind of an action has to be done on
this information it has to come back to
the short-term store the working memory
store and the process which moves
information from the long-term store to
back to the short-term store is
basically called the read tribal process
so basically then we will look into this
part this whole part in this lecture now
the question is what is the existence or
evidence for existence of this long-term
store but again let's look quickly look
into the idea of serial position car now
what was the experiment for looking at
the serial position curve the experiment
was that unlist is given to people to
actually go ahead and read and once you
read this list you are asked to retrieve
it back and as you retrieve it back what
tends to happen is a curve like this is
shown in terms of retrieval so if I look
at percentage accuracy of recall which
is on this side and this is the item
numbers on the list what I tend to see
is that items which are recent tend to
be retry more and items which are at the
the list tends to be they try more
whereas item in the middle of the list
are not rape tribe and so this effect
was called this was called the primacy
effect and this is called the recency
effect and very popular theory we have
discussed this before now this base
basically experiment shows that and the
reason that there are there has to be
two systems of memory there has to be
two stores of memory the reason why is
that in the items which have been
learned at the beginning of the list
they receive a number of repetitions and
so they had retrived back better is
because this goes to a LTM store a store
which stores information a kind of
structure in the brain which stores
information for longer durations of time
and the experiments are done where it
was found out that the primacy effect
items which show primacy effect they
remembered for longer duration of time
why because it was processed think of
you doing the list what happens is the
first item comes in so second item pops
in so we repeat the first item and the
second item third item pops in you
repeat the first item the second item
the third item and so the number of
repetitions that the first item actually
goes through or it receives is n
factorial times so kind of the list
items is there and make a vector low
that and that is the kind of repetition
cetera see so with more number of
repetitions you are prone to more number
of more processing and so shifting to a
store so this basically here this
diagram here shows you that there are
two different kind of stores and this is
the short term store and this is the
long term storage now another
interesting thing is that as we saw that
the short term store which is basically
then improved into the
in memory store that is divided into its
central executive the phonological loop
the VCO spatial sketchpad and the
episodic memory
similarly the long-term store has or the
long-term memory has several
subdivisions so we look into the
subdivision in the and as we move
progress through this and each of the
subdivision we are going to look at or
we are going to study one by one so the
upcoming lectures will look into all of
these stores so basically there are two
subdivisions of it one is called the
declarative part and the other is called
the procedural part so basically the
long-term store and itself is divided
into two stores there is a lot of debate
we'll also look at the debate of what
are the declarative and procedural
parties but basically the difference is
declarative is that part or the
declarative is that type of long-term
memory which you when you retrieve that
you're conscious about it so a task like
thinking about your first birthday I'm
pretty sure that you cannot remember
your first but that but let's say you're
12 class farewell or things like that
now another interesting thing why you
cannot remember your first birthday is
up because there is something called
childhood amnesia we'll talk about it
means at the end of this section but
right now that's the reason that I'm
just given to the reason so basically
conscious things which you are aware of
when you are thinking about it or when
you are retrieving it is what is the
declarative knowledge and procedural
knowledge is those knowledge which are
unconscious so you are basically
unconscious or you do not know that you
are craving it example mostly I give
this example in my class is riding a
bicycle so how do you teach someone to
ride a bicycle so even if I ask you to
give me how do you ride a bicycle it's
very difficult for you to show how do
you ride a bicycle and so there are two
different parts now within this
declarative and procedural part you have
within the declarative part you have
something called the semantic
type and episode it type of memory we
look into these two types of memory
semantic stores world knowledge so
basically facts rules truths and those
kind of thing and episodic is that kind
of knowledge which is basically related
to episode which is basically related to
some kind of event in your life
procedural basically there are four
subdivisions but will not look in detail
into the procedural part of memory so I
just give you a brief overview of what
can come here so you have basically
things which are learned from classical
conditioning things like habits right
and so this kind of structure is there
and also priming priming is another
thing which comes under procedural
memory so things priming is basically a
instance or it's basically a phenomena
in which if you want to if you want to
identify or if you if you are given the
task of perceiving an object just before
perception of an object some information
some very brief information is given to
you and that way if information leads
you to basically remember or basically
recognize that our object that is called
priming so basically I think of it in
this way so when you're going to meet
someone before you meet someone somebody
gives you some kind of information about
that person and that makes you quickly
identify that person now this
information which has been given to you
is basically called priming and
similarly there are two types of priming
one is called semantic priming the other
is called perceptual priming but we'll
come to that when we come to that
particular exercise but right now this
is what it is so let's then start the
usual things let's start looking into
the usual thing of long-term
so what we have done up till now is we
have established that there is something
called long term memory and we have us
to also establish that this long term
memory has some kind of set up which is
that which we look into the upcoming
lectures so basically then in this
particular lecture if we look into the
retrial and encoding our long term
memories basically long term memory
it's basically described as a place for
storage or large amount of information
and as you know from philosophical
viewpoints this has been quoted as a
script book of memories or a treasure
chest so we split it isn't thought of a
place like a box or a chest which can
store a large amount of information so
that is what the conceptualization of
long term memory is these are all
philosophically conceptualization now
the question arises what is the capacity
of LTM so there have been several
experiments which have been done and so
generally speaking the long-term memory
has a huge its it has sometimes it's
called that it has in finite capacity
why because whatever you know up till
now whatever you've learned up till now
in your life and till the point you die
it will all be stored in long-term
memory so basically meaning that most
information that you know in your life
so again that the evidence here is that
long-term memory hasn't in by night
storage so basically but there have been
some attempts to find out what is the
capacity of this long-term storage to
look at let's look at this evidence so
commerce lender he tried to provide an
answer by making two basic estimate one
estimate is the cerebral cortex has 10
to the power 13 synapses and so what
synapse is at if you look at a neuron
and in Iran which is there and these
neurons they connect to each other
through an empty space so basically this
is the neuron this is the dendrite of a
neuron dendrites are those portions of a
neuron which help in communicating so
these are two dendrites which
communicate with each other and they
communicate through both an electric and
electrical messenger and a chemical
messengers or chemical messengers are
stored here but this is something which
comes into the biology of memory and so
let's not get into that particular
framework but then this synapse is the
space between these two dendrites which
are there and so basically this space
allows chemical messengers are basically
substances which are called
neurotransmitters to basically move from
one neuron to another so if this is the
neuron which is transmitting and this is
the neuron which is receiving
information is passed through the
synapse so synapse is there that
particular space avoid which is there
and it is very important in looking at
how memory is
so there's a whole idea of how memory is
told what is the way it is stored and
biological basis of memory says that
there is something called phenomenas
called long-term potentiation and
long-term depression which is how
memories are stored but we will not
discuss on to that really quick please
look into this so this is this empty
voids or spaces are what are called
synapses and so Thomas Lanier he found
out that there were 10 to the power 13
synapses in the in cerebral cortex and
which is the number of information which
is stored in the brain so he basically
created it that one particular synapse
is trained for only one kind of
information and so if it's 10 to power
13 then it is 10 to power 13 bits of
information which is stored huge No
another estimate was made as that there
are 10 to power 20 bits of information
which is the number of neural
transmission made by an average human
lifetime and so this particular
deduction is made on the basis of the
fact that the liar is the life of human
beings in the life of a neuron and based
on the life of the neuron and life of
the human being it is estimated through
computational calculations which show
that 10 to the power 20 bits of
information pass on from one neuron to
the another or that's the number of
connections and neuron actually a number
of neurons which are there they make and
so this is the kind of information or
this is the kind of capacity of LTM but
then both of them are genetically an
estimate of written as I said in genetic
speaking it has infinite capacity now
the question is how does it account for
this infinite capacity so basically
think of the archiving program that you
have in your computer so you have either
a wind
you have something like some other I
don't know the names of a lot of those
archiving systems but then you have
these systems or you have these programs
which help you to compress file now
similar system helps is there in long
term every what it does is it compresses
file but then it uses certain features
which already advanced feature so what
what it does is first it selects what's
information has to be stored and based
on that it also compresses information
and then it provides a key to this
compression so let's look at how
information is stored and how
information is retrieved the duration
and all those things in the next few
slides so basically another question is
we saw that the pudding that happens the
way information is stored in short-term
memory was a caustic in nature and so
there was a very good experiment which
was there which was done by Bradley and
so Bradley showed that if a caustic
words were used if two different kind of
information was fed into short-term
memory and both for a caustic in nature
in the sense that either they had the
same phonology which basically means the
same speech sound and another ones which
didn't have the same speech sound the
confusion was more for those words which
had the same speech sound so P and B
we're confuse more PBE controls were
then P and K kind of a thing and so
basically that experiment showed us or
basically told us that the kind of
storage that happens in long-term memory
is basically a costing now what is the
format in which it is stored in
long-term memory so basically this is in
terms of again Bradley didn't experiment
and found out that this is in terms of
semantic nature so what was the
experiment so what Alan Bradley did was
he gave two groups first he selected two
groups of people for one group he gave
similar sounding word for example map
made and Men two people for remembering
and then he gave on other words for the
same place
he gave people to group for people to
different leads layer lists to remember
now there are two versions of the list
in one version of the list what happened
is people were given similar sounding
words to remember for example and had
her hair kind of a thing or map madman
as he are written here and in the other
list you had my words from the same list
the presentation list but then these
words were not similar sounding so you
have things like pandering because they
don't sound similar and this was to
create a caustic confusion and in the
group B people were given same meaning
words so you see here what happened is
you have the huge word the big word and
the great word all of them have the same
meaning so it's like a tsunami tsunami
generally more synonymous are given and
then another list was created where
people were given words which didn't
have similar meaning so it had different
meaning for example foul old and deep
and recall was done after 20 minutes
participants engage and related tasks
for the task while basically and back
counting so an N back counting task was
used now what is an impact counting
tasks we showed you in the last lecture
in the Brown Peters and task n back
counting is basically a task in which
you count back n units so 1,000 and if
you have to count three units back it
will be 997 994 kind of a thing and so
this is n back you have to keep on
counting back and those has to what the
n-back task is all about and so people
did this kind of a task this was given
so that they should this kind of attack
should take up all their available
attentional resources so that the
rehearsal is not allowed or rehearsal is
not given
so what 20-minute wait was done and
after that when experimenters are the
subjects were asked to retrieve back the
caustic similarity produces very little
effect on performance as well as
semantic similarity so when words which
were similar were they represented or
they were shown to people twenty minutes
is enough time for any item to get
process so when this kind of retrieval
was done it was found out that in these
people
in Group A there was no difference so
there was no difference between people
who were given map map and man to
remember but then more confusions were
seen on people who were given similar
meaning word and so this experiment
basically demonstrates the fact that
these words which had similar meaning
that was what was creating confusion and
this experiment also shows that the kind
of manner or the manner in which
information is stored in long-term
memory is basically in terms of
semantics or in terms of meaning another
reason or another thing for the
existence of semantic evidence I would
say for the existing semantic memory is
basically this is called AVENGERS
forgetting curve so what is the event
cause forgetting curve and how did it
arrive so I explained to you in earlier
lecture that Evan was was a German
psychologist and he was testing his
limits to memory of how much thing he
can remember how much items he can
remember and for how long the time but
if he tried to remember words from a
list then there would be some a
long-term memory or there will be some
bias into it so what he did was he
created a CVC
a consonant vowel consonant kind of a
try gap we call this as a try again so
this triad was so let's say X V and Q
now xvq doesn't mean anything but PA t
would mean something or pad or ca t
would be cat so these have meaning words
and these as a tiger so this kind of a
dragon was then he took a lot of try and
he remembered them and he then retrieved
the these back over periods of time this
is a very simple demonstration a very
simple thing very simple result from his
experiment what he saw that the
percentages of mean saving and versus
the retention interval what happened is
the as inputted arrived or
one day's after 31 days people still
remember this 20% of items from the list
so even when he did experiments he found
out that from the list that he
remembered 20% of items were still with
him he was able to retrieve this 20% of
item even after 30 days or 31 days and
which kept on going for a number of more
days
so basically meaning that there is a
store which allows you to store this
information for longer duration of time
and that also this idea that you do not
get forgetting or do not forget after
this long duration is basically another
evidence for the existence of a store
which stores information for longer
duration time with more rehearsal so
what happens is as time passes the you
don't tend to forget more and this is an
evidence for long-term memory so let's
do a quick review of a long-term memory
so basically the question here is they
travel transfer the information from
long-term to short-term memory as I
showed to you and forgetting is the
inability to basically retrieve
information so we people often talk
about forgetting now forgetting from
short-term memory is very obvious
because items to get stored for 20
second and so we cannot think of
forgetting as a forgetting here is that
again we looked at how does this
forgetting happen so in the last class
we looked at the brown Peter sent out
tasks and the worgen dorwan tasks and
both of them said that there is a decay
kind of a thing and interference kind of
a phenomena which basically leads to
forgetting from short-term memory so
let's look at why do we people forget
from long-term memory how do we forget
things from long-term memory so is there
something called forgetting from
long-term memory or if something is
encoded into long-term memory does it
stay there forever so let's look at that
quickly so basically this is how it
works so this is the sensory memory this
is the working more short-term memory
information is rehearsed here and then
it's passed to long-term memory from the
long-term memory it is retrieve back as
and when it is wanted back to long-term
memory so why do people forget there are
several forgetting theories
which have been proposed for long-term
memory and let's look at some of these
theories so some of the theories which
have been proposed for forgetting from
long-term memory is something called the
poor encoding Theory the decay theory
the interference theory and a retry will
cue theory so some of these theories are
what you find so basically the reclaim
and interference Theory is what also
applies to the short-term store but then
for the long-term store you have two
additional theory so let's look at these
theories one by one so let's look at the
first theory first theory say is that
forgetting happens from long-term memory
because people never encoded that so it
could have happened that a piece of
information was given to you and you
never encoded that information and that
could be one of the reason why
forgetting happened and that could be
one of the fact by forgetting happened
it could be that you will never know
example if as is the question where is
the tilde key in your computer keyboard
so people who have not used the tilde
key
they have no never encoded whether tilde
key is or where is the function key so
people who type some people who never
use the function key they will never
know because they never encoded it that
is called encoding failure theory so
information which is never encoded into
LT M is called the reason for it there
is a short term memory information never
pass from the short term memory to the
long-term maybe so no encoding and that
is the reason for encoding failure here
so some examples are what letters
accompany the number five on your
telephone if that is what is given to
most of you I mean these days you have
these newer smartphones we don't have
these numbers with it but the
push-button phones that were that were
there it had to be had a number of a
number written three digits or three
letters which were written after every
digit that is the question most people
would not have ever thought about that
right and so you don't tend to remember
or vary the number zero on your
calculator if this question is asked
most people do use it and so it's become
so procedural or so automatic as we saw
in attentional theories at the
become so automatic the pressing zero
becomes so automatic that it's very
difficult for you to know where it is or
so according to this theory objects seen
frequently but never but information was
never encoded into LT m and that is one
reason for forgetting from LT m another
reason why people tend to forget another
theory which proposes forgetting from
long-term story is called the reach
rival the failure theory so what does
this theory say it says that not all
forgetting is due to end coding failure
some of the forgetting is due to retrial
failure also so on one poor encoding
theory the first theory says that it was
not encoded but in the next three
theories talk about treat rival failure
something happens at the time of the
retrieval getting information back from
long term store and that must be the
reason why this kind of forgetting
really happens so let's look at those
theories so sometimes information is
encoded in Altium but it doesn't come
back and so you see this is short-term
memory encoding is done but it doesn't
come back visible the retry will failure
leading to forgetting so what are the
few is there or what are the some common
examples that one common example is
reporting phenomena the purity
phenomenon is called people now there
are times in your life when you know
that you know information for example
movie song is coming up and so you are
there looking at it you know the
actresses name
you know that which letter it starts now
you know which heroes she has worked
with when which movie she has work with
but suddenly there is a freeze and the
name doesn't come
your mouth and this is called let they
put some na minha what happens is that
you're not able to retrieve that and
that is called a travel failure also
can't retrieve information that you
absolutely know is stored in your memory
because you know the first thing of this
actors you know vo machine work with a
lot of information will basically mean
that there is somewhere also the name
stored but you are not able to retrieve
it an example I have given so evidence
of forgetting has an inability to
retrieve information why we can't
retrieve information that is what we are
going to see so three theories from very
tribal fear failure section one is a
decay theory the interference theory and
then they travel cue theory so let's
start with the decay theory first and so
what does the decay Theory actually says
the decay theory this is basically the
average percentage of information
retrieved and this is the interval
between original learning of nonsense
syllables and memory tests which is
basically some something like a brain
goes CVC kind of a paradigm so he looked
at try games and this is the curve which
is that so basically the key theory says
that memories fade away or decay
gradually if unused so if some memory is
not used for a period of time it became
and there is a biological explanation to
that also will come to the biological
explanation in a while but that is what
it is so if you do not use information
which is stored in your memory then
there would be a problem and this is
something which we're seeing nowadays
what has happened is the google has
taken up so much of her information
bucharest taken up so much of her life
that we don't try to retrieve
information even if we need some bits of
information what we tend to do is we
tend to look into google we type that
and we get any information and voila
it's there so basically that's a problem
so we don't use it and so I always keep
on telling this to my students that
please use information if you don't use
information it will decay out and one of
the fact is the time how much time is
spent between learning and retrieving
the information that is one of the
reasons of how this particular theory
works so time plays a critical role now
I ability to retrieve info are the
clients with time after original
encoding so as more and more time
happens and you're not receiving this
information the K will decay will lead
to forgetting so let's say at some point
of time when you learn something so
there is a bit of knowledge that you
learn our Sanskrit for example if you
learn Sanskrit in your in your earlier
classes in class seven eight I have not
used it because you didn't follow it you
tend to forget some ass or things like
some other grammar or Sanskrit you don't
tend to remember how the Sun D is made
that's basically conjugation of
sentences how it is done in sanskrit so
basically that's what happened as time
passes on information is never used and
so you tend to forget it so basically
this is what the decay theory is so
basically decay theory is a biological
based theory and so it gives a reason
why decay really happens and what is the
reason the reason which has been
provided is that when new memories are
formed it creates a memory trace a
change in the structure of the brain
chemistry as a new memory is formed from
the neurobiology of memory you'll come
to know that as a new memories form what
happens is new connections are developed
and so when new connections are
developed what happens is there are
number the new dendrites get attached to
each other and information passes or one
neuron gets connected to multiple
needles but what happens is if you do
not use this connections it will be
there away the brain chemistry will take
it away so you finally unused normal
brain metabolic activities will erode
these connections these connections
which have been formed between two
junctions or two dendrites these
connections will erode away because they
are not talking to each other so to your
on should be talking to each other only
then a connection is there but if this
talking stops on how the
neurotransmitter
if it stops passing between two
junctions the receptor two receptor
neurons what will happen is or some
change in metabolic activity within the
synapse happens this leads to
example one of the interesting thing is
known is which is evident is dopamine
deficiencies or Department deficiencies
in d1 d3 d5 kind of a structure so these
are three receptor types on a particular
on particular neurons and so when lack
of dopamine happens here then people
show tendencies which are very similar
to neurotic people and so this kind of
thing happens so if you don't use any
connection for a longer period of time
it will be that way think of it in terms
of a railway store a railway warehouse
so in the olden days people these
railway warehouse used to be somewhere
and so you would see railway lines
basically passing through roads but then
as time has progressed nobody uses those
railway lines or old stations or whole
junctions which are there and so it
withers out nobody remembers it and
there is no real cares about it example
then your New York Central Station below
that there is another station which is
there it's a popular thing which is
there and so there is a whole new
network out there but nobody uses it
anymore and so it decayed and similarly
the brain also decays the information
from the brain also decays by not
getting you so theory not widely favored
today in today's world we know heart
yeah follow this theory because there
are certain brain chemistry's which say
that this kind of degeneration doesn't
happen in the brain then you have the
print appearance theories and what does
the interference theories say so memory
is interfering with another memories is
the reason for forgetting so why do we
forget we forget because one kind of
memory interfere with our other kind of
memory now we looked at what is
interference and we looked at how does
it happen so what happens is that if two
items which are very similar fairly
similar together are brought to their
brought in close proximity to each other
one will interfere with the other or one
will compete with the other so there is
something that there is something called
a fan effect which has been explained by
understand for this kind of thing
farrance so Edison in nearly 1996 they
did this work on how interference really
works so they what they looked at is
that any retrieval cue points to a
particular target this is how they
looked at so if this is a retrieval cue
or this is how you retry something it
project it points to a target but then
assuming that another target is added to
it which is similar in nature this we
travel cue then is shared between these
two targets and so if more number of
competitions are generated what will
happen is an interference will happen
because this is a travel qc1 is now
cueing these targets T 1 T 2 and T 3 and
so what will happen is when C 1 is
activated one neuron is activated or one
Junction is activated now they are not
uniquely connected what will happen is
all of these targets will get activated
and they will interfere with the with
the processing of one now forgetting not
caused by mere passage of time so this
theory basically says that forgetting is
not basically due to passage of time is
caused by one or more competing with or
replacing other memory so the definition
the thing that I showed you what will
happen is multiple targets with compete
with each other so as soon as this cue
is activated this targets will compete
with each other the more similar they
are the more chances that they will not
be retrieved because similarity is one
way of how information is retrieved so
if let's say there are how is the
conceptualization of working memory
there are different bean bags or think
of it in the there are different kind of
structures out there and so structures
which have similar kind of structures
which have similar kind of features are
put into this bin back we look into that
and when we talk about semantic memory
and so what will happen is if
informations which are of similar type
they compete with each other what will
happen is that they will not be
processed so it's caused by one more
competing with or replacing another
memory so if similar items are there
they will compete with each other and so
they will not be able
trivet there are two types of
interference to look at one is called
the proactive interference of the other
is called the retroactive independence
and a very simple paradigm explains it
so let's assume that an experimental
group a group is given to learn a list a
B and an and while they are doing that a
control group is given an unrelated
activity to do after a while the same
group both the groups are now given a
list a C to learn so a B is a list
basically a B is a pair associate list
so you have how what is a bad associate
list in a bad SC at least you have
something called a Q target kind of a
set up in Q target what you have is so
let's say if we have goat and we have
leaf here the goat is what is presented
to you the leaf is what you have to
remember and this is called the bad
associate so a pairing between goat and
leaf is done and this is called the Q
and this is called a target so the while
learning you'll learn goat leaf but
while you're driving I will show you
good and you have to learn leaf now we
have done this earlier on international
theory and in perception all those are
part of perception also where we showed
basically in perception of diversity of
perception where we showed how Ottawa
City really works so basically in this
paradigm then what happens is at a later
period of time you are given to learn
list a see now when that happens god
roll group shows no interference but
then since list a B and list AC has a in
common so this will interfere with each
other and so the learning of a the
running of a C after a B creates this
kind of interference that this is called
proactive interference so here since no
list was done the learning of a B
creates interference with learning of AC
and that is what the proactive
interference is all about in retroactive
interference paradigm what you have is
both groups learn list a B and a B but
group to learn a C and group the control
group doesn't learn anything and so what
happens here is this AC list the
learning of this particular list it
interferes with the learning of the
earlier list
and that is what attractive and
proactive interferences let's quickly
look into what these really mean so when
a new memory interferes with remembering
of old information this is called
retroactive interference example is when
a new phone number interferes with the
ability to remember your old number so
let's say you think you have changed
your SIM card you have changed your
number and when some deletion the old
number the new number interferes with
remembering of the old number this is
basically what is called your
retroactive interference so quick
paradigm example learning a new language
interferes with ability remember old
language so this person here she knows
French and these are the French words
that she knows and so what happens is
after that she learns Spanish no peppier
and peple both are for paper liver
and/or pluma and bloom both of her
flower and so this kind of things are
there which are very similar in the two
languages and so what happens is if she
learns French first studies Spanish
second and Spanish interferes with the
learning of French that is why she gets
an F in her exam and this is what is
called retroactive interference in fact
if interference what happens is opposite
of retroactive interference of an old
memory interferes with new memory so in
in the attractive new memory interferes
with old memory as I saw as we saw that
Spanish interferes with French I mean
proactive interference is the old
opposite the old memory keeps on
interfering with new memory that is
called the proactive interference and so
in proactive interference what happens
is memories off where you parked your
car on campus the past with interfaces
the ability to park car today so what
happens is since you have parked this
car your cause how many times near your
past
parked a bicycle in wherever you are
eating your department so many times at
so many places that that interferes with
the fact that where you park today this
is what is called proactive interference
this is if so old knowledge hampers
because you tend to park at some place
and because that was not available you
part someone else and so the ability to
go back or the automaticity which makes
you go back into the case where you used
to park and not finding a bicycle is
what is called proactive interference so
all knowledge basically interfere as a
completes with new knowledge
now basically as you saw what happens
here is that most both the information
or similar type because it is a parking
situation in both the cases and so
similarity is there another theory which
talks about the failure or which talks
about how they travel failure happens is
called the retrieval cue theory of
forgetting and so what is the retrieval
cue theory the travel cue theory says a
clue prompt or hint that can help memory
to retry so basically when any any
long-term memory is formed as I said it
is a cue target kind of any kind of a
memory is a cue target kind of a system
so memory is generally has something
colon healed or kind of a system so
basically when a memory stored somewhere
in there in the long-term store a cue or
a key is provided to it and this key
fits with this lock of the memory and it
opens it so this cue cue is the clue or
the law or the key for the memory and
the memory is called the lock or that is
the store which is there and so the
travel cue is very important because if
you use a wrongly travel cue you may not
be able to they try also another feature
that you have to know what the travel
cue is that sometimes one memory can
have multiple retrieval cues what do I
mean by that if you want to remember
your let's say farewell the 12th pass
farewell now that is what you want to
remember there are several ways of
remembering it one is the kind of
importance you were given there another
is the kind of feeling that you have one
that they may be in their MB
so that embarrassment which could make
you remember that day or maybe it was
other kind of words people said to you
or the kind of feeling that you have
that day the kind of shock that you got
the kind of emotionality which was
generated and so several events or
several events can link to that memory
and can bring forth that memory and so
multiple cues can link to that memory
and each of these cue has a certain
weight to it the most weighted I mean to
say the most potent cue will have the
highest weight so basically if my memory
that I'm talking about is let's say
remembering an event and the event is my
farewell and there are four cues which
can make it remember for example the day
in terms of what day it was how I felt
that day that is another so my feeling
my emotion is one way of remembering it
or it could be and let's say party an
after party which is making it remember
or some other event at home which makes
me remember it now let's say this
emotionality is whenever I think about
whenever I become emotional I remember
this farewell so it has the highest
weight here right and so these have
another and so each one of them can
think can make you think about this
farewell situation but what would happen
is that this is the one which will make
you the thing more and this is the
highest rate so basically what is there
and similar situation can also occur
where one queue can retrieve so many
memories so there are always all types
of things of that let's look at this
theory so retrieval cue is in this this
is water cue looks like so forgetting
the result of using improper retrieval
cue if you think about a party and if
that is what is retrieving the farewell
and what would happen is there you would
have so many parties in your life so it
could be the farewell party it could be
your home party which is there it could
be some other party with your friends
which is unrelated to the farewell and
and so forth so if party is the fact or
party is the cue that you're using to
try to get retrieval this has the lowest
weight right because you have so many
parties but how you felt that day has
the highest weight and so that is the
most potent thing and so if using
improper cue if thinking of retrieval in
some other way in which it was not
encoded if that is what you are trying
to retry then that is not possible and
so that might not be a good idea of
freight traffic so it rival forgetting
can be basically happening because
people don't have the right they travel
queue now with retrieval cue there are
two things to look at one is called a
recall and the other is called
recognition there are two retrieval
types from long term memory we will
discuss this retrieval end and recall in
detail in upcoming lectures but for now
let us look into it
so importance of retrieval cue is
evident from recall versus recognition
and what is the difference so recall
test must retrieve information which is
learned earlier for example fill in the
blank type of test so those tests which
ask you to remember something from
memory right and as as demonstrated you
are filling the blank type of questions
are mostly retrieval or recall kind of
or a tribal system so here you have to
retrieve the actual information which is
stored and in the cognition test what
happens is it's like in answers in front
of you but then you have to basically go
ahead and match them and so as you will
see that recognition has recalled in
building to it because only if you
recall something if you are able to
recall something and then you will be
able to match it so basically remember
vs no kind of a thing remember worse is
no kind of system so I remember
something versus I know something so for
knowing something you have to have this
remember for remembering something you
have to have the knowing kind of a thing
and so multiple choice tests are
something called recognition yes so for
example look at this question what is
the capital of Finland no one's
is there and so whenever you try to give
an answer she oh she ever give an answer
to that it happens so recall because
when you search a memory for it and look
at these four answers which are given
I'm pretty sure that you know the answer
the answer is as inky and so the fan
what is the capital of Finland there are
four answers now when you are recalling
you are doing a free recall so you are
searching your memory for any
information but in the cognition you
have to have recall also because you
have to recall well where does these
things fit and so recall basically is a
part of recognition and so this is what
a recognition test looks like and so you
will put in to fill Helsinki because all
of them now have a probability of 0.25
one-fourth probability of being
remembering so which was easier recall
and recognition psychological exam would
you rather have filling the blanks of
multiple-choice and it's there it's best
that you have the cognition item is
basically multiple choice questions are
what's on which what I've been used
nowadays everywhere and so this is the
most important kind of examination which
has been used and so this is the most
prominent kind of recall that has been
or kind of a recall system which is used
everywhere nowadays so in this lecture
we looked into some of the what is how
long-term memory is designed what is the
way in which it is encoded and what is
so forgetting how it is stored and what
is the forgetting from long-term memory
or how does this long-term memory store
information thank you
[Music]
you